the off-season programs
were supposed to start today for the
teams that have new coaches they're
allowed to have a head start well they
get no start nobody's going to have a
start i'd be shocked at this point if
there's any off-season program one of
the the issues that the nfl and the
nflpa continue to work on is how the
players will earn off season workout
bonuses now not everyone has them but
there are millions at play here they're
a huge part of the compensation package
for a lot of players and i'm told that
the nfl is is pushing for the players to
earn those bonuses through zoom workouts
wearing heart monitors and other things
to show that they're actually doing what
they're supposed to do another issue how
do
players qualify for the per diem which
really isn't that much money but for the
young guys it's sure you know it's a
nice little chunk of walking around
money although nobody's walking around
right now so you really don't need
walking around money i guess but still
there is money that is hanging in the
balance with these workout programs
because uh how guys participate will or
won't qualify them for their workout
bonuses or whatever they're gonna do
with these per diem so there there's
some business that needs to be taken
care of right
this is the really the first day the
nfl's being
officially disrupted by this still had
free agency everything else has happened
this is the first real disruption and i
don't know that they have a definite and
final plan for how to deal with it i
don't think they do either i mean how do
you deal with it you know i mean yeah
you're gonna i don't know unless guys
start zooming in like you say to the
strength coaches on an individual basis
or maybe it's position by position basis
hey wide receivers everybody be at the
field zoom the strength coach at 12 noon
and he's going to give you a workout and
do his best to watch that you're doing
it i you know that that's about as good
as you're going to get right now i don't
see any other way around that you know
and again yeah this is important stuff
yes there's so many guys in the nfl that
have you know a few hundred thousand
dollars uh associated with their
off-season workout program so uh they're
of course going to want to get that
money in the bank or at least make sure
that that's accounted for and i don't
know how that gets accomplished you know
it's going to be tough tough for new
players tough for the draft picks when
they come back into the league new
coaches right now with new organizations
certainly have an uphill climb to
indoctrinate their system within the
organization it's just not going to be
easy there's a lot of moving parts of
this football season it looks like
yeah and you know what you're going to
have and mike erfulo of nfl media had
the number last week 36 million roughly
speaking in workout bonuses that may or
may not be paid out and you know i hope
they find a way for the players to
qualify for that money or they take that
money and shift it into their salary or
they just do something to make the
players whole it's you know i don't
think the players should be the ones who
are victimized by the fact that they're
ready and able to show up and work out
but circumstances are preventing them
from doing it
can they you know the things i thought
of just brainstorming right like okay
just say i'm playing for the tampa bay
buccaneers you know can can the the can
the team
say something to the players as far as
like this mic like hey
quarterbacks
meet me at the practice field today
all right and you could still social
distance if there's only four or five
quarterbacks there can you put them
through the rigors of a workout and have
a strength coach stand 50 yards away and
bark out orders can you start doing
things like that mike would you be
frowned upon like say if they just
brought the db's in right and it was
just hey we got 12 dbs here here's the
strength coach he's going to stand on
the other field and you guys all spread
out 10 to 15 yards and we're gonna start
doing wind sprints is that a possibility
i mean i don't know am i crazy to think
that
well i i i don't think you're crazy to
think it the reality is in most states
where the nfl does business now we've
got stay-at-home orders so how do you
navigate that that's one of the issues
we're dealing with as it relates to the
draft trying to get i assume permission
from the various states where the nfl
does business to allow
up to 10 people to go to the facility
for the three days of the draft and
they're still
you know awkward optics with it too
because everybody else is staying home
right yes why why should the nfl get
special treatment when everybody else is
finding a way to deal with the
requirement to stay home now it's easy
for me to say because i do my job from
staying home anyway but i'm talking
about the millions out there who are
uh being truly hampered in their ability
to earn a living because they're
complying with the requirement to stay
home so that's one of the other twists
that i think needs to be considered if
the nfl wants to do something like that
you know we were ranting last week about
uh how the the pictures keep showing up
chris of guys who are finding a way to
work out and then they're draping their
arms around each other and taking a
photograph and how ridiculous that is
and how stupid that is and hopefully
hopefully guys find a way where they can
balance getting themselves in shape but
also complying with the requirements
that currently are applicable one last
quick point before we go how much do you
think this is going to hurt the new
coaches especially the first time
coaches there's only three of them kevin
stefanski joe judge and of course i knew
i'd forget the other one but oh matt
rule of the carolina panthers um how do
you think this is going to affect them
not having the ability to have an off
season program well we we've seen it's
doable right i mean we saw jim harbaugh
come in and be very successful his first
year with the san francisco 49ers i
think they went what 13 and three so it
can be done uh but
it's not gonna be easy and that was a
special circum set of circumstances that
jim harbaugh took over you know i look
at guys like joe judge and matt rule
uh where i go man first time head
coaches along with kevin stefanski and
there's a lot of team building that goes
has to go on there with those
organizations
i i think they're certainly way behind
more behind the eight ball than a guy
like mike mccarthy mike mccarthy ron
rivera been there done that but
especially mike mccarthy with the dallas
cowboys hey listen they got a lot of key
positions already in place for that
football team there's not a whole lot of
turnover with the dallas cowboys yeah
they need to do the new learn the new
offense and language and way of life and
all those things but nonetheless the
culture of players the the mainstay of
guys is still there and i would think
they would be a little less affected by
less than the
the panthers with bridgewater and
somebody or daniel jones in his second
year as a quarterback and a new coach
those are tougher obstacles to overcome
than dak prescott getting him in there
you already got ezekiel elliott amari
cooper and all these other proven
commodities
and the one advantage matt rule has
we've discussed this in the past with
this draft being watered down from the
standpoint yeah that's right you can
gather rule comes directly from the
world of college football and has
coached played against knows other guys
in the college coaching industry maybe
better than some nfl coaches at this
point and can tap into some of that
knowledge and that may give him a little
bit of an edge to balance out the
disadvantage of not having an offseason
program
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports